pressing the live button now
okay good evening and welcome everybody
to this evening's virtual meeting of
stratfor naval district council's
planning committee
my name is councillor peter richards and
i will be chairing the meeting
this evening a few housekeeping issues
if i made to start with please note that
tonight's meeting is being live streamed
and it's been recorded for publication
on the council's website and
youtube you will all have been provided
with the council's etiquette
for code of etiquette for virtual
meetings in advance of tonight's meeting
however just to reiterate a few of the
saving points
please make sure that your device is
either plugged in or fully charged
we don't want to drop out because of
battery issues uh please remember to
mute your microphones when you are not
speaking and of course remember to
unmute them when you are
told to speak if you could please
indicate in the chat bar
uh if you do wish to speak and i will
call you in at that
point um if you could also please turn
off any of your other devices or the
very least turn them to silence so that
we can
proceed with the meeting without any
interruptions
if for any reason you do get any it
encounter any i.t problems causing you
to drop out of the meeting please make
every effort to get back in as soon as
you possibly can
if you can't there is a number in the
meeting chat now that you'll be able to
call and it will
help you out if you're unable to rejoin
for any reason you will have been deemed
to have left the meeting at that
point and will not be able to take part
in any further debate
on uh on an item at that stage um
i can confirm as well that checks have
been made in
in the company of our solicitor uh that
all members of the committee can
see and hear the meeting and they have
read all of our papers
to introduce our officers if i may start
uh with committee services we have
anne banks with us our solicitor tonight
is mina mack
and our planners are charlotte dix
louise coleman and joe brooke
ably assisted by ben ellis from our
licensing team
and we have dale barker as our planning
manager
dale i understand that you have a
statement you'd like to make at this
point
thank you chairman my role here tonight
is to provide impartial advice and to
assist members
in their decision taking thank you thank
you very much
we do have a number of members of the
public who have
registered to speak they will be
speaking via phone
members of the public if when you are
called um if you could unmute your
microphone to that point you'll need to
press star and six to unmute
we'll check that we can hear you and you
can hear us and then we will ask you to
speak
um you will be given uh three minutes um
in each case
and you will be given a 30 second
warning before your time is up i will
run that through that with you all
um as when we get to that stage
okay let's move straight into the full
agenda then so first of all we have
apologies and do we have any apologies
please
gentlemen we have apologies from
councillors adam eden
and parry marvelous thank you very much
disclosures of interest next members if
you can indicate in the chat if you'd
like to make a disclosure
i will start us off um item number
four on your uh on your agenda which is
uh land at
galway farm uh in norton lindsay i am
the ward member and have registered to
speak
so i will be removing myself from the
meeting at that point
um and passing over to the more than
capable
uh councillor fleming who will chair for
that item
do we have any other disclosures of
interests counselor curtis please
yes uh thank you chair i'm i will be
speaking
uh sorry just trying to play on item
number
oh goodness i'm sorry item number seven
eve uh one five seven eastern road which
is also in my wards i will
remove myself from the meeting at that
point no problem at all thank you very
much um anyone else have any disclosure
please indicate in the chat if
you do i'm seeing a lot of shaking heads
so i'm going to assume that is a no in
which case we will move on to
minutes members are you happy that the
minutes in your engender pack
fairly reflect our meeting of the third
of february in which case i will sign
them
off i have a lot of thumbs up
that i believe is a unanimous thumbs up
so i will go ahead and sign those um
when we next have an opportunity okay in
that case we'll move to our first item
which is the land at galway farm in
norton lindsay i am going to hand over
to councillor fleming now to chair from
here so council fleming over to you
right we'll uh we'll push on them with
application reference 19 stroke 01618
oblique stroke out london galloway farm
brick kiln close norton lindsay
uh and i'd like in for the first
instance to invite the planning officer
um charlotte dix please
to uh to make her presentation
thank you very much chairman let me just
share the presentation with you
can i just check can everybody see the
the title page
yesterday oh yeah i can thank you thank
you very much chairman
so the site is indicated on the map by
the black circle
the application site is located within
claritin parish and adjacent to the
village of norton lindsay
and the parish of wolverton this slide
shows the relationship
of the site to the village of claverden
itself
this slide shows the application site
edged in black
the site is an agricultural site which
abuts the rear boundaries of the
properties on brick and
close richards the east and the rear
gardens of dwellings on wolverton fields
to the south
the parish boundary with wolverton is
shown by the dotted
pink line along here at the rear of the
properties
with the boundary with warwick district
and norton lindsay shown by the
darker dotted pink line running
effectively north to south
the public right of way is also visible
marked by the
the dotted green line and you can also
see the listed building
to the south of the site
so this is an outline application for 10
local needs dwellings for cleverden
access is a matter for consideration but
all of the matters are reserved at this
stage
the indicative plan shows where the ten
dwellings could be cited along with the
internal road allotment and open space
officers have raised objection to the
indicative sighting of the properties
this image shows an aerial photo of the
site and the wider area
the site is indicated by the yellow star
here and shows the relationship with the
existing built form within northern
lindsay
and the open fields to the the north and
west as well
so this photo shows the access to and
the rear elevations
of properties on brick hill and close as
as viewed from curly lane
the nature area mentioned in the report
is on the right hand side of the photo
and the right away accesses is just off
to the right of the photo as well
so this photo shows part of the front
and side elevation of number 12 brick
hill and close
on the left hand side and essentially
within the photo this shows where the
access into the site would be located
so this area along with this area to the
right hand side of the photo
is part of the nature area approved as
part of the original brick kiln close
development
so this photo is taken from the public
right of way facing south towards the
application
site the hedge on the left hand side of
the photo
shows where the eastern boundary of the
site would be
the properties in the background are the
dwellings on wolverton fields
and you can see that the ground level
lowers towards these properties
so this photo is taken from just within
the site itself
again you can see the hedge essentially
within the photo now
with the properties on brick kiln close
and their rear gardens on the left-hand
side of the photo
with again the dwellings on wolverton
fields on on the right hand side of the
photo
so this photo is taken panning round
from the same location now
facing towards the west and towards the
the distant public right of way
this is taken again as you pan around
from the same location
now facing towards the north and the
line of trees as you can see them here
and the hedge is
effectively marking out the public right
of way which which runs to the north of
the site
so this photo is taken from the rear
gardens of the properties on wolverton
fields
facing northeast towards the site itself
which is just beyond this
post and rail fence here the trees in
the background of the photo are the same
ones we saw in the previous photo
and this is the the eastern boundary of
the site
this last photo is taken from the front
of the properties on wolverton fields
with the listed building on the left
hand side of the photo
and just showing the views from
wolverton field through to the
existing field and the sites beyond
so just to clarify there are updates to
the consultation responses within the
update sheet
and officer recommendation is to refuse
the application for outline consent
for the reasons and notes which can be
found on pages 24 and 25 of the agenda
thank you chairman
ah thank you thank you for that
um charlotte that was that's excellent
uh right you are then i'll move on to
the the paris council who have
registered to speak
um we've got uh councillor simon lawton
who's chairman of cleveland parish
council who's supporting the application
um has he is he in on the phone at this
point
council lawson would you would you like
to come in please
all right try again okay council lawson
are you there
ah yes you have to press
star six to unmute your phone all right
we've got you now hello okay thank you
very much hello
yes all right we can hear you now
what a system it's great um you'll have
you'll have three minutes to speak um
and we'll give you a warning
30 seconds before the end of the three
minutes um
so that you can wind your your speech
down at that point
okay thank you very much if you'd like
to carry on start now please
thank you chair um the parish council
fully support this much-needed
development
on reading the report before you we were
astonished at the recommendation
after over 18 months of what we
understood were positive discussions
with your planning officers
your papers show our reasons to support
this application
we do not understand why this
interpretation of our adoptive
neighborhood plan has been so
misconstrued
the arguments that it fails so
completely to adhere to policy h2 is
baffling to us
the application matches it exactly i
should know
as i wrote the policy with a fellow
chartered surveyor i have the report in
front of me now
the report also claims that it does not
meet identified housing needs
of course it does our council frustrated
at housing association's efforts in the
past
agreed a bespoke housing needs survey
agreed by stafford district council
officers
the proposal exactly matches the results
of the survey
it is in effect a bespoke development
for the parish
the report also cites an increase in car
use as the reason for refusal
this is crafts everybody in our rural
parish needs a car
there is no option as we have virtually
no public transport
this is not a valid reason for refusal
the report also claims
it is unacceptable in the green belts
there is no value
argument for this as the consent for the
adjoining
10 unit developments of brick getting
close past all of the green belt
restrictions so why should this differ
so on balance well much is made of the
design of the layout sorry
this is an outline application so
considering the draft layout graph
designs etc etc
should carry no weight at this stage so
on balance
and there being no alternative locations
within the parish and certainly no
none within or near the village center
this is the only deliverable development
site available it is not a
for-profit project the trustees are all
village volunteers
in some ways it is unique councillors
this application is perfectly acceptable
to the parish council
it dovetails perfectly with our
neighborhood plan is well supported
by our residents and at our referendum
it has also the support of our district
councillor and our county councillor
and our unique cleverland land trust
made up of so many villagers
who wish to see our village thrive
i think that's all i have to say at this
stage if i have time i would just like
to say
that as a district councillor i was
involved in
in a similar scheme which became kites
gardens
this was a a a affordable housing
project
that has now won awards and the same
planners came up with reasons for
refusal
that were completely overturned by the
planning committee
kites gardens is now an award-winning
scheme housing local villages and was
opened by princess anne a couple of
years ago
thank you councillors for listening to
me and if you've got any questions i
would
happy to take them uh
thank you very much mr lawton we've got
a couple of questions for you queued up
um first i'd like to bring in chris
mills he's first one in with a question
thanks mr chairman um simon
good evening to you um good evening
chris
local need um
can you explain this local need to me um
and is is this the number of houses
are we get are you getting affordable
housing on here
yes yes can i explain uh council of
mills
and to all councillors um we
the the village in our referendum uh
recommended
well we decided that we needed
affordable housing we certainly do
um we were dealing with warwickshire
rural housing association
and one or two other um housing
providers and uh we were frustrated that
their
lack of effort so as a council we
decided to commission
our own unique housing needs survey uh
which was done a couple of years ago
it was done perfectly in in
collaboration with stratford district
council officers
and the result was that we got 30
responses
uh 20 were deemed to buy the planning or
housing offices to be not valid
leaving an amount of 10 and these 10
were approved for four two bed market
price
houses four affordable price houses
one two bed to rent and and a single one
for uh
uh for again for uh market rent
the the fact that the planning report
says that this
application is not supported by our
housing needs survey is is completely
baffling to us because
it doesn't just explain it exactly
matches
the the report i've got in front of me i
i don't quite understand how
the planning department can come up with
a
with a um interpretation that is so
completely bizarre
okay so thank you very much does that
answer your question
counselor mills please froze
my screen right um
i now have uh councillor dixon who wants
to come in with a question castle dixon
thank you chairman uh catholic lawton uh
good evening to you good evening i see
from the reading of policy h2 which as
you said you wrote so you'll be familiar
with
small community-led housing schemes
within the report before us we have a
situation whereby
we've got comments from both cleveland
parish council and your two
neighbouring parish councils we also
have
uh almost two a4 pages of objections
from
third parties we sometimes on our
reports have
comments from supporters there isn't a
single indication in our report of a
supporter
other than there is reference within the
comments from the parish council of
100 members of the cclt which are
obviously
the the members of the trust um i don't
know
what proportion of the membership that
is perhaps you can
clarify that for me the claverden parish
council's comments also indicate that
the local need is supported by
your other parish local councils
now that's obviously supported by
cleveland but it doesn't seem to be
supported by wolverton or
northern lindsay so i was wondering how
can you
uh confirm to me that this is a
community-led housing
scheme as opposed to a possibly
members of the trust housing scheme
thank you
guys
do you want to come back with an answer
to that question
um
are you still there can you still hear
us
we can't hear you at all
german i think we'll have to put that
question to uh perhaps some of the
trustees yeah later as well i think
you're right
okay um yeah i also had a a
question from peter henshaw serif and
we'll probably move on with that one as
well
and do the same thing there
okay so we've now
finished with with paris council move on
to the
to the next uh set of speakers
uh and this is where we've got uh quite
quite a quite a few people in that
uh in that group
so if you can bear with me just one
second because i'm trying to do this
honest on a separate ipad
i can help you out if you would like
chairman uh
that would be most grateful i've got it
okay who is that speaking now is that
council lawson back again
simon this is simon lawton yes
unfortunately my
my signal was cut
okay so you whether you want to continue
to ask the question or if you want to
make it
i heard the question but i'd like to
answer it is this the question from
councillor dixon
yes indeed okay could you respond then
please
yes okay um
hello right councilman dixon thank you
very much for your uh your question um
just to say that the community land
trust was set up a number of years ago
uh by the community and it was set up to
specifically try and provide the village
with the
affordable housing that it meets um it
started off with a hundred members i'm
not quite sure about the current
membership
because obviously over these years a lot
of interests are sort of weighing
because nothing happened as we were so
frustrated with housing associations
um i think your comment about um norton
lindsay
and uh and wolverton councils is we
originally when this planning
application was made we we sort of had
tentative support
from wolverton and northern lindsay um
i'm not sure why that support waned
um but your your point is noted
okay thank you very much for that um
i've got another
another question for you if you're still
here i'm here
right uh councillor hensha serafin do
you want to place your question please
yes thank you chair uh simon
uh these houses are they mainly for
younger people of clavidon to stay
within the village area
um well i think it's it you you can not
derive from the survey because it's not
age related
um but yes the whole point of this type
of housing was to
allow should we say elderly people who
would like to downsize
to look at that to free up family houses
within the village center
and also for example somebody young my
son for example councillor
he uh he has been in cleveland he plays
cleveland and rugby and cricket teams
he has to live in wellspawn because
there are no houses
around here and this is the precise
point it is designed
for two-bedroom houses for first-time
buyers
it is designed for large bungalows for
retirees
it's a broad brush approach and that's
why i said in my report
that it is a bespoke development it's
actually
pretty
no i do understand thank you very much
thank you thank you
okay council lawton thank you very much
for that
um you can either stay on the line and
listen on the phone or you could go
and listen to the to the live broadcast
and uh okay thank you
right we'll move on to uh the
the next uh set people will go for
the objectives um councillor easter
brook
chairman of wolverton parish council
speaking on behalf of norton lindsay
paris council in wolverton paris council
oh you can hear me yeah i can hear you a
bit quiet but we can hear you
i'll speak up then thank you very much
so i'll make a start
yeah carry on this is a joint submission
by wolfton parish council and northern
lindsay parish councils we object this
application on the planning grounds
which we'll go through in a second
we don't believe this can be cured by a
better application
we don't believe the development meets
the housing needs for any parish
both councils support affordable housing
for local people and walton parish
council recently supported an
application
for an affordable development in the
parish this development though is in the
wrong location and is the wrong housing
mix
collaborate housing needs survey density
needs for 10 dwellings but in clavedon
not elsewhere the development cannot
meet cleveland's housing needs
as that need depends on ready access to
the shops doctors surgeries and other
amenities
in claverden ctlt's planning statement
admits that previous
previous affordable developments on the
edge of north lindsay to meet the joint
needs of club and walter and northern
lindsay
not all taken up by families from
cleveland despite significant
identified need this clearly
demonstrates that the location is
unsuitable for cleveland's housing needs
to expect different this time around
ignores the history
the proposed development of breech lane
including does not have this problem
as it is in the built-up area of
cleveland the development does not meet
housing needs in walton parish which is
being satisfied by properties under
construction or applications that the
parish council supports
and northern lindsay has no identified
need for affordable housing
and the development does not match the
identified mix of housing needs for
claviden
even if it were corrected the location
still remains unsuitable
we don't believe the development is
capable of providing sustainable
development
it's more than two miles from
cleveland's crucial amenities and there
is no sustainable transport
northern legend walters have minimal bus
services and no other public transport
there's no safe or continuous pedestrian
access or public transport to cleveland
and cycling walking is along dark unlit
roads
which will be especially difficult for
the older demographics and those
with children the development as well
um will inevitably lead to increased car
use and ecological impact
in contravention uk's ambitions to be
carbon neutral
the site itself is unsuitable the
development will encroach on open green
belt countryside
have an impact on the openness of the
green belt and the arden special
landscape area
and be out of keeping backland
development
surface water is also an issue from the
field where development is proposed
it flooded houses last summer and
additional runoff caused by the
development would make this worse
we don't believe there are other reasons
that might outweigh these issues
and the applicants claimed very special
circumstances are generic and could
apply to any
scheme so in conclusion these issues are
fundamental to the development and
cannot be resolved by any changes to or
conditions placed on any scheme in the
proposed location
and we support the recommendation the
committee report on the grounds it set
out
thank you okay thank you very much
uh we've got a question from uh
councilman mills thanks miss jim
good evening um actually you almost
answered the question i was going to ask
um you're saying two miles from the
closest
amenities you say two miles
yes yes in northern lindsay it's not in
cleveland
right so that is it's two miles to the
local shops
yes there's a shop there's a doctor's
surgery
um yeah and um
where how far is the school away from
this proposed development
or is there a school walton parish
council's wolverson primary school so
he's very close
uh cleveland school will be again a
couple of miles away
right okay thank you very much thank you
uh thank you councillor mills um does
anybody else have any other questions
for
uh for councillor easter brook
okay in that case uh cancer easter but
you're free to go
and you can carry on listening on your
phone or you can go to the live stream
and uh thank you very much for your
input thank you
all right i'll move on to the to the
supporters
um now we've got
we've got a a thing here where we've got
potentially james horner or john horns
to speak who will actually be speaking
please
press the r6 on your phone so you're not
having it
hi there chair it's james horner
speaking jane
i'm right okay all right you've got
uh you've got three minutes you'll get a
30 minute
uh 30 second warning when you're close
to the end of the
three minutes and uh if you'd like to go
start now please thank you chair and
committee
before you just before you start one
thing i would like to say is
uh so that everybody knows um we've got
richard sapco
john horner toby lapid
and philip lowe to answer questions
should we need it anyway sorry carry on
that's okay thank you chair so a
thorough appraisal of the planning for
has highlighted several objections of a
technical nature
and we've taken the decision as a board
to address all our objections and
textual note to the committee
and then a lot of our time summarizing
the key elements so
i believe that to fully appreciate the
exciting nature of this application
it must be understood why the land trust
exists now the land trust is a
not-for-profit community-led limited
company
with currently 63 subscribers drawn from
cleveland and surrounding parishes
and from the subscribers we've got a
board of eight unpaid voluntary
directors
the trust sold purposes to benefit the
communities of cleveland parish
and the local surrounding villages
including northern new zealand will
return wooden world and the others
now we know there are housing needs in
local areas that are not being met
the 2020 wrcc survey audited by the
stratfor district council included 10
affordable homes required in the local
parish
now our goal is not to tick a box in
order to allow market development
but to build only those 10 houses and
deliver a high quality sustainable
affordable home
that current and future residents would
be proud to live in now the objections
concerning locations of proposed
development is something we have long
tried to address
but the reality is there were no other
locations suitable that would satisfy
the needs of our community at a sensible
cost
of all the sites considered curly lane
next to brick hill
close was the only location where the
landowner was altruistic enough to
accept a below market land price to
support the needs of the community
the discount on the land together with
our not profit status enables us to
build discounted market houses
and this qualifies our proposals and
exempt development under the cs10 and
national planning policy framework
now mindful of the royal and greenbelt
location we have dedicated a huge amount
of time and resource into the design
alexis has been placed on sustainability
and community within the scheme
and approach the design with a holistic
lifestyle frame including orchards
allotments play and wildflower areas for
residents to enjoy
whilst in the buildings we've created a
spacious contemporary light filled home
that are based on the vernacular the
local architecture
and finishes that reflect the rural and
agriculture environment
it should be denoted that we have
deliberately trying to avoid the
affordable little boxes so common at the
back of market home developments
now the report has made us aware of the
norton movie parish and walton concerns
for the lack of local facilities
to support the investment and they'd
like to rely on private car use
a stated bypass council like simon
lawton private car use is a reality
rural limited
living not limited to curly lane and the
existing warranty county council review
bus service will help address some of
this public transport concern
regarding local facilities since the
report we have sought to engage with
norton lindsay parish
council and will continue by supporting
establishing facilities deemed necessary
for the village
finally my last concern i'll ask is that
is how the housing needs to be met if
our application is registered 30 seconds
the 10 affordable homes are still needed
if including the part of a market
development at 25 inclusion this would
lead to a minimum of 40 homes being
built
so in summary the land trust is a
community-led not-for-profit venture our
solution is sustainable
affordable small-scale development by
directly addressing the identified local
housing needs for the benefit
of all communities around cleveland
parish including the villages of
northern new zealand pressing back at
woodland road
langley wolfton hatton sri lanka thus
the committee has a unique opportunity
to support a pioneering development of
affordable housing
embedded in local community needs not
commercial market
wants i ask that committee is minded to
approve our application
with the condition that we provide a
viable surface water drainage solution
so that we can proceed to discharge the
reserve matters with a detailed
application
and we welcome any questions to myself
or the wider board who have joined me
on this call thank you thank you very
much for that
um i do have some questions for you i
think the first one in was
uh councillor mills did you have did you
is that or is that a previous question
that must be a previous mistake
okay okay we'll go on to uh councillor
dixon please
thank you chairman uh mr horner um
i think in your opening remarks there
you uh explained
the width and brett of the trust
as uh having i think you said 63 members
and
covering not only clavedon but nearby
villages
can you confirm if those 63 members are
as it were residents of cleveland or is
there a good
membership from the other villages
including not
lindsay and wolverton etc and uh
given that uh mr lorton
the council of lawton wasn't able to uh
or didn't
in actual fact indicates his response to
why there were no letters of support
in respect of this application from
members of the community the residents
etc
which we often see but we do have lots
and lots of letters
from people who are objecting thank you
mr horner if you could reply to that
please
yes thank you councillor dixon um i
would like to put that to um to our
secretary uh dr john honor
great thanks chairman and thank you well
cersei thank you chairman land trust for
inviting me to comment
and thank you tony for your question
um the 63 members yes we started with
100
uh in 2012 and in fact we had a lot of
enthusiasm
when we were negotiating for a site by
the
telephone exchange in the centre of
claverden unfortunately the
owner of the site suddenly turned around
and said he wanted to market prices or
land
which is about a million pound an acre
and that blew
any form of affordable housing out of
the water um
enthusiasm has weighed a bit within the
population
and we now have 63 active members the
um the issue of public support i think
you'll find that
not that many people think they need to
support something
but certainly when you get a lot of
objections
you um the people tend to write through
objections
the site was identified
in the neighborhood plan specifically
and in the neighborhood plan referendum
eighty-four percent of the parish who
voted there was a thirty some
mid thirties high thirties with um simon
no high turnout
84 voted in favor of the plan
so to say it's got support in the parish
is correct
can i can i just can i just ask you a
question there
um you haven't particularly haven't
particularly answered the question that
was asked of you
uh how many people outside of uh of
claviton have actually are actually
within your group
within the group we've got one in north
lindsay
truly has got one pin pinley green
we used to have somebody from um from
sniderfield
lowsenford and warwick
right so effectively we're looking at 50
plus
within cleveland itself then oh yes i
mean it's
we were set up by cleveland parish
council and the first meeting was
certainly cleveland parish people
because it is initiating launch meeting
okay thank you very much for that i
think you know
the neighborhood plans uh is all
all well and good but we're here to
answer the questions that the
councillors are asking
so what i'll do is uh i'll move on to uh
councillor jennings has a question
yeah sorry it's actually already been
answered now so i'll put my hand down
okay thanks thanks matt okay fine um
next one is uh
councillor crump how do you have can you
go with your question please
thank you mr chairman i don't know what
is his question for mr horner or dr
horner
um the third reason for the refusal
relates to flooding um
i've got flooding portfolio with uh
workshop county council
and obviously the lead flooding
authority
uh hasn't been able to remove its
objection
uh in light of the documentation in
front of us
um yeah the phrase is they've retained
our objection insufficient information
has been provided to formulate a
response
so i think the pro or you know
personally i think
this application has got quite a lot of
merits but i'm concerned about this
in particular i just wondered why this
um
wasn't completed or satisfied with the
local flood authority
before the application came to committee
please
thank you counselor come for that
question it's a it's a very good
question
and for that i'd like to bring richard
sapko out to uh
to answer that one on our behalf thank
you
mr steph curry you're there
mr sap cody you there then
ah perhaps you haven't pressed star six
on your phone to unmute yourself
mr sapco can you hear us now
it's richard zap coach okay carry on
then please
so um we were only advised um
hello can hear me now yeah we can hear
you fine
okay so um the reason why it's taken so
long to
uh to get the the um
the drainage done was the in fact
because the land is
so heavy we couldn't get an engineer
and the um the tractor into the top of
the
land to be able to get the
trial excavations to be done and that's
been going on since
uh september because in september were
asked by the planners to do the geranius
survey and we were not advised
before then um that the uh the drainage
survey was required so
we just struggled to get um get that
done
and we're trying to get it done as soon
as we can in fact um
we're going to do in the next couple of
weeks now that now the weather's
picked up i think basically we we did
we were not asked to do that until
um mid-summer i think it was about
july august and then we had to get an
engineer uh appointed which we've done
and by the time we tried to get the the
work from um the wet weather quarter
sound
okay right here thank you for answering
that
can i just come back on that counselor
uh yes absolutely
absolutely yeah obviously um
you know we've got a major project here
um summer or september
it is a reasonable period between now
and i know we're only in early march
so it is a reason or beings
have not been able to get onto the
ground because it was so heavy does it
indicate there is a problem there
that needs to be sorted out properly
beforehand so
again i i don't want to be you know i
don't
try to be facetious or anything like
that that's a genuine inquiry
so just to indicate there is a problem
with the land there that needs to be
rectified before
before this was uh goes ahead
okay thank you yeah if i
shall answer that
yeah so yeah it's a valid point but
until you do the
we get an engineer and do the survey we
don't know so it is a valid point but
just because it's it's wet now does it
mean that we can't
carry on and i think as it's an outline
planning application
if we do have it with um a condition or
reserve matter
pack that the way forward and let the
engineers and the experts
come to the right decision um
chairman james would it be worth me
commenting because of
the the issue of the timing of the
requests
yes i think so yeah right yes thank you
councillor
i've come in because i was i'm having to
manage the submissions on the
planning um the workshop
county council flood authority flood
team
in invited or asked for clarification
on the land drainage on february the
10th 2019.
um it's normal practice for officers to
pour statutory consultees when they ask
for further information to forward that
information
to the developer and in fact the officer
had been forwarding information
from from statutory consultees up until
december
end of december actually the middle of
january
but this request was not forwarded
um and it wasn't forwarded until the new
planning officer took over
on august the 5th so there was a massive
six-month delay
over the summer when we'd had the
harvest
and the ground was was was accessible by
tractor
um double is by the time we'd organized
the fairhurst
he had done the tenders and got
fairhouse boat
um the farmer because it's his living
had plowed the land
and drilled let's put seed in and if you
plow the land you lift it up
you aerate it and you can't actually go
on it otherwise you
you crush the crop the crops and you
just wrecked your crop
that was always it started raining end
of august early september and it hasn't
stopped raining
we actually i farm adjacent farm
we only got onto the land to do some
spraying with a wide
tired sprayer lightweight right wide
tired sprayer
this last sunday we haven't been able to
get on that no one in this area has gone
on the land
since september and that's the land
okay thank you very much for that i've
got one other question now
uh it's uh councillor curtis sorry i
hope you haven't forgotten what it was
[Laughter]
no not at all um mr homer i think in
your comments
um you mentioned that this land was for
sale at the low
market price which obviously if we're
looking at a
site for affordable housing that's a
very attractive proposition
without giving any details away can you
tell the committee
by what sort of percentage below market
price this land is being offered
yes absolutely thank you for the
question um
again i'm going to put that to our
secretary dr john horner who's got the
details of that
thanks very much um i don't think it's
any secret
it is a 90 percent discount
um sorry um can i do
sorry chair can i just um come back on
that yeah sure i just want to make sure
i didn't
miss here or committee didn't miss hear
that
nine zero percent nine zero percent yeah
it was the only site we addressed we
we talked to a number of respective
landowners who would sell to us
none would sell except one actually we
had two
one was refused on fanning hercules farm
and the other one because it's too close
to a listed building
the other one was the telephone exchange
and the then landowner
led us in a negotiation for two years
and then turned around and said i
thought you'd be
you'd come to your centers and pay me a
decent price and
uh it was only uh richard thai david
evans who actually came to us and said
here you are
i'm happy to let you have the land on
one condition but you name it after my
wife
thank you very much that's um
okay very helpful thank you thank you
chad it is an incredibly generous offer
by the by the landowner okay thank you
very much
um i'm sure you'll all continue to
listen on the live stream now
um and uh thank you very much for your
input um
thank you chad okay next thing should be
the agent but i think basically the the
trustees have been the agent for this
anyway
i don't think we've got a separate agent
listed have we
so so from that perspective i think the
next
person will be speaking will be
our award member right
good evening we'll move to the woman
okay and then
cancer richards you're on
thank you very much uh members you've
heard today from a number of speakers
who've raised a series of points arguing
both sides of this application
one thing that has become increasingly
clear to me is that the application as
it's evolved
has become a little convoluted and
fragmented rather than focus on
the points that have already been raised
i'd like to draw your focus
and attention to the reasons given for
refusal
the first thing i draw your attention to
is that this is an outline
application with all matters reserved
save for access
that's confirmed on page 15 of your
report in paragraph 2 where the final
three lines
state that alongside the principle of
the development
access to the site is the only matter to
be considered at this stage
layout scale appearance and landscaping
details are reserved matters for future
consideration
turning now is the reason for reasons
for refusal point 2 sets out concern
over the indicative
form of design and layout not fitting in
with the rural character and
distinctiveness of the area
as we know layout scale and appearance
are all reserved matters
and so this reason for refusal should
really be dealt with at reserve matters
stage
the proposal at this point is purely
indicative and so i do not believe this
is a sound reason for a refusal
now looking at the third reason for
refusal this focuses on drainage and the
lack of required information to
demonstrate a suitable drainage strategy
we've heard from the applicants already
about the difficulty they've had in
obtaining the required reports
not least of which because of the global
pandemic that has prevented a lot a lot
of this work being done
they've also been frustrations due to
the weather and the field being used for
crops
to my mind this reason for refusal can
be overcome
either through a condition that being
the need for a suitable drainage scheme
an assessment being presented to the
satisfaction of the authority
or at the reserve matters stage
similarly reason 4
relating to the impact on the nature
area and appropriate mitigation being
put in place
this would form part of a reserve
matters application at which point the
detail of the layout
scale appearance and landscaping will
all be known and appropriate mitigation
can then be put in place
so really that leaves us with just one
reason for a refusal which focuses on
the green belt issues
and a meeting of a local need taking the
green belt issues first
both our core strategy and the mppf make
allowances for development in the green
belt
specifically policy cs10 point a
states that a small scale development
which meets a housing employment or
other identified need
by local community in accordance with
as-10
subject to it not being more harmful to
the openness of the green belt would
not be an inappropriate form of
development in principle
policy as 10 says similar small-scale
schemes for housing employment or
community facilities
to meet a need identified by a local
community in a parish plan
neighborhood plan or other form of local
evidence on land within or adjacent to a
village
would be seen as acceptable and
therefore supported
policy cs15 also supports local needs
schemes in any settlement across the
district
and cleveland's ndp policy h2 supports
small-scale community-led
housing schemes this proposal as you
know
is being led by the cleveland community
land trust
a not for profit trust set up by
volunteers
from the community for the community it
is in itself a community-led
function these policies clearly support
the principle of the development
provided there is evidence of a housing
need
so knowing that reasons two three and
four can be overcome through condition
and or
reserve matters stage and with policy
that supports the principle of the
development in the green belt
at this location it simply leaves you as
decision makers to be satisfied
that there is sufficient evidence to
demonstrate a housing need
that evidence has been presented through
an updated housing needs assessment
undertaken in may 2020
page 16 and 17 of your report sets out
the detail of that assessment and
confirms
that the housing needs survey and
claverden's ndp have identified a need
for 12 properties of different sizes
clearly that demonstrates there's a need
for 12 homes where this proposal is
seeking to provide
10 of those homes now in its current
form
the mix of property type doesn't
directly fit those that have been
identified
however i must reiterate the point i
made earlier this is an outline
application
with all matters reserved save for
access that includes
layout scale appearance and landscaping
the current layout and housing mix is
purely indicative and can be altered
ahead of reserve matter stage to suit
the identified need
if you're uncomfortable if you're
uncomfortable in granting based on the
indicative layout
again it is in your gift to condition
the housing mix
should you wish to move towards a grant
so members as ward member i'm happy to
support the principle of the development
in this location but i will leave it to
you as the decision makers
to satisfy yourselves that the
identified needs
can be met by this development and that
appropriate conditions are in place to
ensure landscaping
design drainage and the nature of
mitigation
will be met before or at reserve matters
stage
thank you very much thank you very much
councillor richards thank you
um right i've already got a question in
uh from councillor jennings you'd like
to go ahead with that please
i think i probably pressed that too
quickly but i think you might have
covered it right at the end it's just
the mitigation for the loss of the
nature reserve
um your thoughts on that i mean
i'm surprised it hasn't been addressed
because it's been going on for about 18
months or so
sure i i think the point what that i'm
trying to make is until
there is clarity over exactly what uh
the layout and design is going to be
and knowing what land is available to
mitigate for the the loss
and the losses are very small it's still
nature reserve and i don't like to see
the loss of nature reserves
it's a small portion and can be
mitigated but until we know exactly what
that is
it's very difficult in order to be able
to put mitigation measures in place
so at that reserve matter stage when
there's detail of the scale layout
design etc
that is where the community lands
traffic trust will be in a position to
say
this is how we're going to mitigate the
loss but
we can't get to that stage until we've
dealt with the principle of development
which is
in real real terms what we're doing
today excellent thank you very much
okay thank you very much councillor
richards any other questions
right you're uh you're free to sit back
now for a little while and
uh and and be free of it so
thank you very much thank you john
right we're now gonna move on to
members technical questions and officer
responses
um so do we have any questions ah
no no cancer janice has a question
thank you chairman um i just i just
wanted a bit of clarification
on the housing needs survey it seems to
be
see very it's confusing um i want to
just give you a quick bit of
clarification on that
yes of course counselor um in terms of
the housing needs survey
from 2020 it identified a need for
four one bed bungalows uh four two bed
houses
uh four two bed local market houses
three three bed local market properties
and one three bed shared ownership
property
and the actual proposal that we have in
front of us today
is for nine two bed properties which
would be made up from
four forty percent discounted market
housing
for number 20 discounted market housing
and one affordable rent and then we've
also got
one three bedshared ownership that's
proposed
as part of the scheme in terms of the
the proposal meeting the identified need
the housing the council's housing and
enabling officer has raised objection in
this regard
doesn't consider that the proposal does
meet an identified and unmet
community-led
housing need there's also concerns
raised in terms of the proposed content
of the scheme in terms of the type size
and tenure of the properties that are
proposed
and how they would reasonably meet the
identified need in the housing needs
survey
and also lastly in terms of the
appropriate arrangements for the
delivery of the scheme
um this hasn't been satisfactorily
included within within the planning
statement to show how this would be
carried out
um to satisfactory meet the the need
so follow-up question to that wouldn't
that normally be wouldn't those
be addressed at the uh
reserve matters application or is that
this is um in terms of the application
and as an outline application this would
only be acceptable in terms of the core
strategy policies and the nppf
if it does meet a local identified need
so we need to be sure at this stage that
that there is a proposal on the table
that would actually go some way to
meeting that need which unfortunately
currently we don't have in front of us
okay thank you okay thank you charlotte
thanks very much
um next question for counts from
councillor mills
please
hi charlotte um thank you um charlotte
is this
outside the built-up area boundary is it
is this this the site is um
some distance from cleveland village
boundary itself
um it's approximately about 2.8
kilometers
from cleveland village uh which is
approximately 1.7 miles
um it's it actually adjoined to the
village of norton lindsay so the
properties that we saw on
on the planet earlier are actually in
the village of north and lindsay
right thank you and um the the
this nature area um and that that will
completely go it'll be up it would be
gone would it
once this um
can see someone shaking their head but
uh will it be completely destroyed
it wouldn't be completely destroyed the
access to the site is proposed
through part of the nature area um if i
can show you
a plan just bear with me a moment
i think it's the extension of the
roadway that cuts through it isn't it
that's correct if i um
can just share my screen with you
are you able to see the plan yes thank
you
so this this is actually the the plan
from the
original application for brick on close
which is the 2009 application i referred
to earlier
so these are the the properties on brick
hill and close and this is the nature
area as approved as part of the
application
so the access drive would actually go
through this section of the nature area
here
okay super duper thank you very much
charlotte thank you thank you
if i may share just to follow that point
up um councillor richards made
uh a very good point in his presentation
that that area of uh nature
area that's lost could be replaced
within the site
and that would be absolutely true that
would be absolutely correct
if the site had sufficient capacity to
handle the 10 houses that are in the
description
and the parking and the gardens and the
landscaping
and the screening and the nature area
and at the moment
we haven't seen that and that's part of
the problem with the application we
can't see that this application
site can get everything on it that it
needs to get on it and that's why we
start discussing
the illustrative layout not because
we're expecting the illustrative layout
to be built
but because it needs to show us that the
site can accommodate everything
and that's not what it's managing to
achieve at the moment and of course if
you grant permission
you do grant permission for 10 houses
yes
we've got reserve matters to sort out
what those 10 houses look like
but you've still got to get 10 on there
and that's going to be the challenge
so you can't sorry thanks dale so you
can't actually plan the mitigation until
you know
you could put it almost it's basically
whatever what you're saying
yeah okay right hang on a second
i've got a question from councillor
crump
thank you mr chairman it's probably a
question for mr barker
uh good evening mr parker um just a very
quick one
um it's been mentioned several times
that it's an outline application
and most of the details should be coming
forward
in the reserve matters obviously you've
just mentioned if we
approve 10 in the outline you've got to
build 10. um
my concern and you probably couldn't
tell it lights the flooding
and the lack of training system that's
come about
um how much weight does this
objection from the lead flooding
authority have
and then outline application considering
it may be coming forward in the reserve
matters and
be be fine um yeah i'm just slightly
confused about it probably haven't said
that very well
but hopefully you've probably
interpreted well haven't sat next to me
for
several years at planning community so
if you can come back
with a sort of answer i would be very
much in your debt
there dale thank you thank you
councillor i think i can translate crump
into english
i think i can do that
when you grant an outline planning
permission you need to be satisfied
that the site can be drained at the
moment the only proposal
are in front of you is draining by soak
away of some sort
and you know that there have been
drainage problems in the area in the
past
you know that they haven't been able to
get on site over winter
to carry out the test because it's so
buggy
if there's another alternative on the on
offer for example
we've identified a roof which a pipe can
follow to get to a discharge point
that can go to the the local flood
authority if the league local
flood authority are happy with that
option
then we can go forward because we've
established that it can be
drained at the moment there's only one
option in front of us
that's soak aways and
the local authority big local flood
authority are
um not satisfied that soakaways will
work and as you've heard the applicants
haven't been able to demonstrate
that circle ways will work does that
answer the question
that does mr parker thank you very much
for turning crumpism into english so
most kinds okay thank you very much
i have another question in from
councillor mills
thanks mr chairman charlotte um
uh grade three agricultural land
um is that low low grade
pretty much uh yes i mean in terms of
the loss of the agricultural land itself
um we wouldn't raise any objection in
this regard
if the principle of the uh the housing
development would be acceptable
um that's that's great thank you
okay thank you very much for that any
other questions
before we wrap it up no
okay thank you very much we'll uh we'll
move on to
uh to members debate then please uh does
anybody want to kick that one off
ah matt jennings wants to speak carry on
matt
okay yeah well
with this application it's one of these
ones where i'm
the whole idea and what they've done
that
to me all makes sense but
i just don't think there's enough
information
in the application at this stage i mean
um
it's been going on for 18 months i would
have said
it's a shame that possibly they didn't
have enough spend another six months
just getting it
getting it right um i say this the
flooding issue
um it's concerning to me that the fact
that they can't get a
they can't get anything onto the land to
try it out because it's too boggy
i'm no expert in drainage but
it would immediately raise flags as far
as i'm concerned especially just having
uh soak aways um i think
see if this was to come back to us at
some stage
and all these sort of niggly things were
all ironed out
i'd sort of i'd be sort of it i'd be
leaning towards
being in favor of it but i think at the
moment it's just not quite there
that that's those are my initial
thoughts at the moment
okay thank you very much councillor
jennings i have a similar feeling
that uh that this this wet ground really
does
does bother me and it makes me think
very carefully about this one
um well bring in uh councillor dixon
please
thank you chairman um my concerns very
much
around the aspect of community-led um
when i saw this application before is on
the report etc
i uh looked at exactly where it's
positioned in relation to clavidon
and i don't know that it could actually
be much further away from the village
uh it obviously is within the parish of
cleveland
but then my questions regarding uh the
trust
and the comments initially that the
trust was set up for cleveland and the
uh
immediate surrounding villages and
residents etc
and yet the membership of that trust is
very much clever and oriented
um if there was support from norton
lindsay parish council for this
i might be of a different impression if
the application
had come forward uh from representatives
of norton lindsay again but
quite simply i do not see this as being
community led
from from the the people who it will
mostly impact
and it would mostly impact upon the
residents of norton lindsay and
if there were some letters of support
that would also help me
to come in favor of the application
i appreciate affordable properties
in the green belt extremely difficult
philanthropists are very few on the
on the ground and to have somebody who
is prepared to release land at 90
below market value yes a million pounds
an acre
that is the going rate in cleveland i'm
sure it's about the glowing rate where i
am um but at the same time um
and it's very difficult to find such
land and i i have
sympathy with that that viewpoint
but essentially to produce a local
housing
scheme for predominantly cleveland
almost as far away practically two miles
from claverden village
just isn't the right location i don't
think um
if if henley was proposing something
right on the boulder
of my ward i think i'll probably have
some concerns etc
so nice ideas wrong place i'm afraid in
my view
unless it had the support of norton
lindsay and the residents
of norton lindsay thank you thank you
castle dixon
um councillor kendall thanks
chairman um i think a lot of what i
wanted to say has already been said
mainly by councillor jennings actually i
think uh
almost completely in agreement with what
he said um i will
just give a bit of credit to the ward
member he came
that close to convincing me uh really
close
but i've got to say it the whole feel of
the application feels like once
nearly there it's got all the right all
the right
aspects i like it but it just doesn't
feel like
quite a complete application um and so
for that reason
i'll be uh going with the office's
recommendation uh
to refuse this i'm not sure if we've had
a proposal i'm happy to propose that
we refuse but bear in mind i would be
very happy to see this come back
as a completed application in the future
and would look at it very
very positively but that is a formal
application a formal proposal to refuse
chair i i don't know if if you're a bit
stuck
you seem to have frozen
yeah sorry i dropped out there i don't
quite know what happened
so i was just about to say to councillor
mills
thanks mr chairman thank you um yeah
i can't say i'm i'm liking this very
much um
mainly because it's you know um
this two miles from the from the
amenities you know
about the same for a school as well and
we've got young people there or even
retired people
uh perhaps retired person wouldn't want
a car you know to go a long way to walk
for the communities
young people a long way to walk um
you know their children um
and it's outside the built-up area
boundary it's not going well for me
uh mr chairman i have to say thank you
okay thank you very much
i yeah i was going to say i should have
dropped out a bit there
um and councillor kendall has already
made a proposal to refuse
um we have a secondary and councillor
jennings
um i think really we should we should go
to the vote now and
and see where we are with it please okay
i'll uh i'll kick it off and i'll uh
i'll say i'm for the proposal to refuse
um right and would you like to to go
through the
uh through the roll call please
oh is that is that frozen as well sounds
just frozen out now yeah
so is that something back chairman
you're back
right okay we were waiting for you thank
you
so i'm sorry i missed what you said
though chairman um i
i vote to support the refusal
so you're for refusal yeah thank you
councillor kendall
councillor kendall four thank you
councillor crum
councillor crump been starting to get a
chance to speak um
he cut me off um i reluctantly
in that for the proposal to refuse i
think it has got some merits
um but it needs to come back in a
different form
i'm very very similar to councillor
kendall it's like my homework
years ago uh good effort but come back
and do it properly
um it's got a lot
muted well it's yes it's got lots of
merits to it
on in favor of localism and for local
houses
um but i don't think it's quite quite
there yet so
reluctantly i will go with the officer's
recommendation and the proposal to
refuse
thank you councillor curtis
broadly in agreement with councillor
trump but i'll keep it shorter but i'll
abstain
thank you councillor dickson councillor
dixon
four thank you councillor hence your
surfing
council interested finn um i agree with
councillor crump's uh summing up of it
it it is a good scheme but it does need
sorting out properly so
olive stein thank you thank you
councillor jennings
councillor jennings for council mills
council mills four thank you one two
three
four five that's six four with two
abstentions
chairman thank you very much so
on that basis of of eight two six
two we're gonna go for refusal as per
the officer's recommendations
thank you very much
right and i my next job now is to hand
back to
to councillor richards for the next item
on the agenda which i'm sure you will be
glad about
no no no council fleming thank you very
much for
for sharing that uh very ably as well um
we will move to our next application
which is application reference twenty
zero one three three five
f u l uh it's caffeine and machine on
bamboo road in essington
our presenting officer is louise coleman
louise are you there and could you bring
up the presentation please
i am here can you
see the presentation i certainly can
yeah
thank you very much okay perfect um
the application site is identified by
the annotation
of ph public house on the plan together
with the
black dot and it's located in the open
countryside 1.4 kilometers west of
eddington village
it's identified by the site edged in red
and is located within the felden
parkland special landscape area
established mature tree planting
um bounds the northern boundary of the
site which adjoins the a422
dense tree planting lies within the
northeastern part of the site
and woodland abuts the eastern and
southern boundaries with agricultural
land beyond
a public right-of-way lies approximately
244 metres south of the site
and also approximately 190 meters
northeast
hounds hill cottage lies to the west and
holly cottage lies approximately 170
meters northeast
on the opposite side of the a422
the application site is an established
public house which serves food and
operates a bed and breakfast
with managers accommodation
the application will continue to operate
the same uses but is seeking to
regularize
some additional peripheral uses which
occur within this site and
has resulted due to the success of the
business enterprise which now imp
provides employment to 40 local people
the premises is now known as caffeine a
machine and activities at the
property have been diversified to
include a theme bar
and cafe as well as a place of
recreation and assembly for car and
motorbike enthusiasts
including external spaces laid out for
visitors to display their own motor
vehicles
and special events being hosted on the
site
initially on busy days vehicles resorted
to parking in the highway
however the applicant has sought to
address this by expanding the car
park area into the field to the west of
the public house
this application seeks to regularize
this but also to reconfigure the
arrangement by introducing
areas of new tree planting in between
the car parking spaces
and creating a new two-lane vehicular
entrance
they propose to close the existing exit
point
and change the existing entrance into
the exit these measures will increase
the visibility displays and also reduce
the likelihood of vehicles queuing on
the highway
thereby improving highway safety the
proposals also seek rep
retrospective consent for the creation
of an overspill car park area to the
rear of the site
retrospective consent is also sought for
a large teepee
located towards the north eastern
boundary of the site
this is a photograph of the tp
and these are views taken from the
banbury road
in addition they are also proposing
retrospective consent for the erection
of three smaller teepees located in the
rear
for a temporary period between the first
of october to the
31st of march each year this is
requested to provide additional
sheltered areas within the site
and to enable the business to operate
during restrictions placed by government
due to covert 19.
this is a view of the tps when
approaching the site from the existing
entrance finally three display plants
at the rear of the site and the use of a
ground floor room
for ancillary retail use is also
requested
turning to some additional photos this
is a view of the current
western car park area taken from hounds
hill cottage
showing the existing bund and shrub area
between the site and the adjoining
neighbor
additional tree planting is proposed in
here
the lower photograph is the wind the
wind
sorry the other photograph is the view
of the side gable of hounds hill cottage
this is a photograph of the approximate
location of the new entrance from
banbury road
and this is a photograph of the exit to
be closed
there are a number of updates to note
including comments received from the
forestry
commission and also revisions to the
wording of condition 9
and an additional external lighting
condition the recommendation
is chairman is to grant subject to the
conditions and notes
as detailed in the committee report
thank you chair
fabulous louis thank you very much for
that we will move straight to our
speakers
and what i will say before we call in
our first speaker is for those that are
speaking tonight if you could please
turn off your live feeds
there is a slight delay and we also get
quite a lot of feedback
um to us as well so it does tend to slow
the meeting down slightly
if you could please follow one on your
phones or your handsets that would you'd
be better place to do that
um councillor karen jones is our first
speaker
she is from aldeminster parish council
councillor james can you hear me you may
need to press start and six to a meeting
i can hear you can you hear me i
certainly can welcome good evening
so you will have three minutes we'll
give you a 30 second warning before your
time is up
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start thank you chair
to provide a place of assembly for car
and motorbike enthusiasts
this application seeks to expand
caffeine and machine to a scale
unsuited to the location and nature of
the site
the business has progressed these
developments with no apparent regard to
the planning system
and is now seeking retrospective
planning permission
as stated by environmental health motor
enthusiasts attract noisier vehicles
to be clear these are sports cars
performance cars adapted cars
and vehicles with pre-catalyst non-euro
compliant engines
visitors even arrived by helicopter yet
this is with
this site is within a special landscape
area and aldeminster is an lsv4
this development is not sensitive to its
surroundings
and is not compliant to nppf cs12 cs22
or as10
the a422 is not cycle friendly there is
no bus service
and pedestrian access to the site is not
permitted
a car or motorbike is needed to visit
and over a typical weekend
the business generates more than 740
additional two-way trips
many of these from a distance with 40
employees
staff trips alone are equivalent to that
of a mid-sized housing development
the additional parking spaces provide
greater capacity than the four public
car parks serving ships and towns
ships and town centre with only small
bar within the main building
the applicants have pitched a tp to add
extra capacity per serving alcohol
a structure with low noise attenuation
the committee must agree that this
application does not support the
transition to a low-carbon future
and is not compliant with cs1 moving on
to the specific situation of houndsville
cottage
these residents now live with a vast car
park on the border of their property
a request to rebuild a wall to provide
privacy and security
was refused by the applicant it was
deemed unnecessary and inappropriate
the pros proposed landscaping could take
up to 15 years to provide an adequate
screen
so scaled back parking capacity is
needed to buffer the property from the
site
these residents are also threatened by
new access and a 10-car stacking system
on their boundary
cars in the stacking system aren't
parked so drivers can continue to rev
engines
a noise nuisance with air polluting
impact
the proposed access does not deliver
better forward visibility
than the original access to the hounds
hill pub and it comprises
it compromises the safe access to an
exit from houndhood cottage
more examples of why the site is not
suited to be a large-scale venue are
provided in your agenda pack
with video footage of noise that could
be deemed a nuisance available if
requested during the q a
the site is formerly a peaceful rural
setting it is not suitable for a large
and inherently noisy outdoor venue
the application has no submitted support
from the local community
and the parish council urges it for it
to be refused
thank you very much councillor jones if
you could stay on for a couple of
questions
members do we have any questions for our
parish councillor please
council mills first
good evening um has there been any
consultation between caffeine
and machine and parish council
uh yes um one of the representatives the
caffeine machine has attended
um at least one parish council meeting
to
to advise us of of the pending
application
fine thank you very much
we do have another question uh from
councillor jennings please counsel
jennings
yeah thank you very much chairman um one
question about the highways that you
just
you so you just mentioned that uh
there's uh
it's dangerous yet highways don't seem
to think so
your thoughts on that um are you talking
about the access or the highway
um my point about the fact that the a422
is not cycle friendly there's no bus
service and pedestrian access
is actually alluding to to the
sustainability of
of this site the only way of actually
accessing the site is by car
or or a motorbike so therefore it's an
it's a sustainable issue that
um we've got got a concern with
okay thank you very much
okay thank you members are there any
other questions for our parish council
member please i'm not seeing much action
in the chat so i'm going to assume
that's a no in which case council james
thank you very much for your
contribution this evening you're
probably best placed to continue to
watch on the live feed but you are of
course
thank you for your time thank you thank
you very much
bye bye okay our next speaker then
is an objector um miss sally russell
um mr russell are you there can you hear
us you may need to press star and six to
unmute your phone
star and six i am here can you hear me
we certainly can welcome good evening um
similar vain to before you've got three
minutes uh 30 second warning will be
given you can stay on for questions
afterwards
otherwise whenever you're ready feel
free to start
thank you very much classical machine
has attracted so many people
it can have up to a thousand vehicles a
day and so the grounds are being
converted into an extra car park now
with provision for some 220 cars
so it has basically become a large car
park with insufficient
infrastructure to match the car park
size
and unable to sustain this volume of
visitors
the accompanying noise levels constitute
a public nuisance
the noise and disturbance from traffic
arriving parking within the property
and then leaving has a huge impact on
our lives
may i point out that in contrast the
impact from the previous business
was minimal you may think that these
comments are based on my perception of
noise and not on reality
however i am a motorsport enthusiast
i am secretary of the classic racing
motorcycle club
and i organize and run some very high
profile race meetings
at race circuits throughout the country
so i am extremely conscious of the noise
constraints that we have to work with at
race circuits
like brands hatch silverstone and
dollington park etc
and with decades of experience i can
tell which vehicles are connected
to caffeine and machine arriving and
departing and which ones are driving
past at a constant speed
i plead with you not to move the
entrance to 50 meters from our property
this really fills me with horror the
noise from vehicles will become a
constant disturbance and the notion of a
stacking system once vehicles are inside
implies engines running close to our
boundary the bund
is a mere 11 meters from our boundary
with a car park 18.6 meters from us
no planting of hedges and trees can
dissipate the noise and pollution
sufficiently
to prevent it impacting on our lives our
house recently suffered from subsidence
caused by the roots from an ash tree
outside of our property
so our house insurance now is based on
there not being any trees growing within
15 metres of our property
so we don't want any trees planted
between the buns and our boundary
so please do plant trees and shrubs on
the caffeine the machine side of the bun
but that and that would be the best
solution for us as long as our boundary
wall can be increased in height
this would give us instant protection in
terms of security
and noise pollution during quieter times
even if the car park is not full and
most cars are parked away from our
property
the arrival of these vehicles will still
impact on us
the noise from engines popping and noisy
exhausts as vehicles approach and break
to enter
will impact on our lives and well-being
leaving an entry our property far more
difficult and dangerous particularly at
weekends
if you reduce the number of car park
spaces it would instantly reduce the
volume of traffic on the road and
improve safety for all road users
following lockdown one last summer a
blocked booking system permitted
vehicles to only arrive and leave at
certain times
this condensed the noise into particular
time slots and went some way
to ameliorate some of the noise issues
particularly with reduced numbers
this seemed to provide a good working
model both for classic
for caffeine the machine and for us and
therefore it makes sense to maintain
this system in perpetuity
and by making this small change it
reduces the requirement for a large car
park
and a change in entrance and the
necessity for extra temporary
constructions
this solution would benefit everybody
and the local
residents thank you mr russell thank you
very much for that um i will see if our
members have any questions for you
members could you please indicate in the
chat if you do
counselor jennings is first council
jennings please
thank you very much chairman um is there
a wall currently between your
your property and uh this
the applicant's property and if so
have you actually put in for planning to
increase the height of the wall
the the war is in existence it actually
doesn't belong to us it belongs to the
land owners for caffeine and machine
it is currently about 1.6
1.8 metres high
okay thank you thank you very much both
of you
um do we have any other questions for
miss russell please uh please indicate
in the chat if you do
i'm seeing a few shaking heads and very
little action in the chat so i'm gonna
assume it's a no
miss russell thank you very much for
your contribution this evening again you
probably best place to continue to watch
on the live stream
you are of course welcome to continue to
listen on the phone but i think the live
stream is probably best
but thank you again for the time thank
you
okay uh we will now move to our
applicants
um and their agents so first of all we
have uh mr keith williams
and we also have a mr macan the
applicant himself
could i ask if either of you could hear
me or can hear me if you press star and
sticks it will unmute your keypad
and hopefully we'll be able to hear you
both super um
i'm here i'm dan mackin um if you can
hear me okay
certainly can thank you very much uh
are you going to be doing those speaking
or is uh is missing oh yeah
is that he's available to answer any
sort of technical planning queries that
any of the committee may have
okay in that case um you have six
minutes between the two of you feel free
to use as much or little as that as you
like
and whenever you're ready please do feel
free to start
very good thank you and back in february
of 2018
phil mcgovern my business partner and i
took on the hounds hill pub and bed and
breakfast
and after several months of renovation
and restoration we opened caffeine and
machine on the 27th of october
2018 as a pub a cafe restaurant and bed
and breakfast with a focus around the
automotive community
ranging from enthusiasts to
manufacturers charities to local
communities
we aim to provide somewhere for
like-minded people to meet and engage
from the first day of operation we had
to react to a significant volume of
visitors
and we rented a tp to help accommodate
our customers in the wet and wintry
conditions
we have always taken an active role in
ensuring that our site remains safe
and we continue to do so on an ongoing
basis within the first few weeks of
opening the doors
we hired a team of car park marshals and
instructed a professional health and
safety firm to conduct a specific risk
assessment
focusing on traffic management on-site
in the following months we engage with
the local police and the authorities
including licensing and environmental
health and we're invited to attend the
safety advisory group meeting to explain
our business
share our operational guidelines and
risk assessments and receive targeted
feedback and suggestions
we created a list of caffeine and
machine commandments which were handed
out to visitors
to remind them to remind them of the
rules when traveling to and from the
site
as well as what is expected of our
guests whilst visiting us
we have attended many parish council
meetings in both older minster and
eddington
to answer questions that councillors or
residents may have had
we have kept our district and county
councillors up to date with any relevant
developments
and we have attended community forum to
provide regular updates of our business
as and when it's been required
whilst we acknowledge that we are unable
to control individuals and vehicles on
the highway
and that we have actually no authority
to try and do so we do everything we can
to ensure that the site and the local
area
remain safe along with another member of
our management team
myself and phil have taken active roles
in the local community speedwatch
program
we've engaged with our customer base
through the use of social media and
on-site events highlighting the
importance of road safety and
responsible driving
we held an emergency services community
engagement day in conjunction with
essington first responders
attended by both the main and ancillary
emergency services
to further highlight the importance of
road safety
the section of the a422 where caffeine
and machine is located
is not a clearway and there are no
double yellow lines
despite the fact that it may be legal
for cars to park on the grass verges
as has been confirmed by the police in
the past due to the disruption it could
potentially cause to the local area and
our neighbours
we made the decision to refuse entry to
anybody that we believed had parked on
the grass verges to walk to caffeine and
machine on foot
we had ampr cameras installed on the
entry and exit of the site so that we
can monitor the cars who arrive and
leave through a combination of social
media
our marshall team and our cctv cameras
we are able to ban any vehicles who
behave anti-socially either on
or in the close proximity of our site
as part of this application we are also
requesting the use of the previously
used camping field
as an over-spilled car park so that we
can do all that we can
to ensure that vehicles refrain from
parking along the a422
the highways authority and environmental
health have both
no both lodged no objection to this
application
including the vehicle capacity
suggestions that we have outlined
to satisfy the demand of the business it
is safer to have guests park on our site
in a controlled and marshalled
environment rather than parking along
the road and walking to the site in an
area well outside of our control
in the first 18 months of operation
prior to closing due to covid19
caffeine and machine employed over 50
people from local areas
we used many local suppliers from
stratford-upon-avon and the surrounding
areas
and we raised over six thousand pounds
for local and national charities
perhaps a small contribution in the
scheme of things but one we were very
proud of given the significant
challenges that many young businesses
face in their early months of operation
we hold monthly mental health awareness
evenings to support our community
and have guests come to speak about
their experiences
we support our staff through various
training and development programs
and are in the process of enrolling one
of our team onto a catering and
hospitality apprenticeship
the increased number of visitors to the
area has benefited local businesses
economically
we regularly speak with customers who
visit us and tie their trip with a
longer stay in stratford-upon-avon and
the surrounding areas
providing further economic benefit to
local businesses
we hope that you can see that we're
obvious we are a responsible business
and request your support in furthering
our development to become a real asset
to the district
thank you and there are no further
comments from keith at this stage
but he is around for questions lovely mr
mackin thank you very much for that
uh we do have uh one members indicators
a question already so
uh council dixon if you would ask please
thank you chairman
good evening mr mackin um good evening i
if we are minded to uh to to grant
permission this evening
um the concerns obviously being
expressed
uh from residents at houns hall cottage
is uh is obviously one of noise
pollution
and noise spheres which they have now
there's obviously
a wall which is on your own boundary
but earlier on in the presentation we
did see a photograph of the bund
which on my reaction to that photograph
was that's a very small bund
now i was can i pose a question to you
that if
uh it was a secret requirement to erect
what i would describe as a sound
reduction noise fence
barrier along the top of that bund
rather than rely upon vegetation to
reduce any sounds
what would be your impression and ideas
as to whether or not that would be an
acceptable condition to you
sure so well thank you for the question
i suppose
a couple of things one is is related to
um to sally's comments around the
uh the noise of cars firstly there was
one mention of cars being stacked and
therefore having engines running uh
not too far from her house i suppose the
the key thing to mention here is that
the the operational plan and the layout
um that has
been provisionally um put in place is
that actually there would be very little
reason for any cars to be
to be waiting uh in close proximity to
her house
um with the intention of us being able
to use the over spill
field that would actually in busy times
direct the cars directly
away from the road um with no real need
to to wait there
in terms of the the bond the as has been
regular discussions with sally to be
fair we we have no reason to make it any
larger than that at the moment
um i understand that the way that this
would work is that one of the conditions
is that we submit a landscaping plan
um we're certainly happy to work with um
with sally and gordon
to to put something in place that that
makes sense for them
um you know i didn't realize about the
insurance uh concern
that sally had with relation to the tree
planting
we're more than happy to to consider
that and in terms of the
the the request that you have when you
say um rather than just the vegetation
are you meaning
and to simply increase the height of the
boat
it was suggestion that there are by
motorways and the like
sound reduction barriers fences etcetera
something like that could work counselor
dixon i'm just going to step in here i'm
just very mindful of the fact that what
your proposal could be seen as a
material change to the planning
application that's presented to us
and and if we go along those lines we
may be inflicting something on the
neighboring properties that would be
unsuitable
um i'd like to move on from this perhaps
that's something we can put to our
um our offices and see what their view
is but we'll do that when we get to that
stage
so agree that gentlemen thank you um
okay
um there are no other members uh
looking to ask a question i will ask one
if i may you talked before about the pub
as it was before you guys moved in so
you also bought the pub
that pub presumably was a relatively
active pub was it before you got it
um it was active in that it was trading
i don't think i would be doing a
disservice to it to say that um
andy and elaine had done a fantastic job
through a a considerable
tenureship of the building um i think
it'd be fair to say that
it was maybe getting a little tired so
again and i
i understand that the comparison that
sally raised is that
you know when you compare what the the
sound and the noise levels may be now
currently
compared to what it was then i think if
you had compared it with
a busy and bustling successful business
back then
actually the difference in the
comparison wouldn't quite be as stark as
it
as it is potentially now thank you yeah
i think
what i was trying to get to was it was a
it was an open live active pub
before you you guys moved in was that
the point i was trying to get to rather
than noise things but i think you
answered that and the answer to that is
yes
okay um thank you very much um no other
members have indicated their desire to
ask any further questions i've got no
further questions
so um thank you to you both uh we
haven't heard from keith but um uh
thanks to him anyway for for being here
tonight um again you're probably best
place to continue to watch the live
stream
uh but thank you for your time thanks
thank you
okay um very patiently waiting is our
ward member councillor o'donnell who has
five minutes to speak we'll give you a
30-second warning and we will ask
questions afterwards
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start thank you chair good evening
committee um i would suggest that the
key to this application is managing the
expectations of both the applicants and
the residents
the applicants have indeed front loaded
this application by engaging with both
the county council and the ward member
they've attended parish councils and
also attended a specific forum
that i organized between residents and
the cafe machine team regarding ongoing
concerns around noise and traffic
around the establishment in keeping with
nppf paragraph
83 we welcome rural enterprise
in the district and the 40 jobs linked
with caffeine in the machine
are very much needed especially during
these difficult times
as we emerge from pandemic we need rural
establishments such as caffeine in the
machine
to encourage spend and footfall within
our district and to sign post customers
visiting them
to go to more parts of our district
however such establishments must also be
mindful of their surroundings and the
potential
impact they have it could be argued that
caffeine in the machine is a victim of
its own success
and has expanded far quicker than
anticipated and the applicants are
playing catch up with retrospective
applications
and it could also be argued that it may
not be the right location for such a
bustling and successful business
as you all note the constant and
consistent complaints
listed were noise and cars revving on
leaving and entering caffeine in the
machine
the volume of traffic in cars the impact
the unfortunate impact it's having on
sally
russell um and the people in houndsville
cottage and the impact upon the
surrounding countryside
which has been fully explained by
councillor
karen jones and again by sally russell
now louise within a very well balanced
and thought out report has addressed
most of these concerns and applied a
number of considered conditions
however caffeine in the machine is on a
sizeable site of almost seven acres
and residents do raise the concerns with
me that it could potentially become a
festival venue
and they want clarity around the purpose
of what the venue and establishment is
for
and i would argue that with regards to
policy
cs22 it states the expansion of
businesses in their existing locations
will be supported
subject to the scale and type of
activities involved
the location and nature of the site is
accessibility including public transport
and impact on the character of the local
area so i would argue
that the volume of cars is a consistent
concern and with two-way journeys going
over 740
over a busy weekend it's a justified
concern as someone who lives in a
neighbouring village
i can attest to the increased noise
levels that we hear
however i would suggest therefore that
the application for additional parking
spaces bringing the capacity to 220
parking spaces
comparative that of a small supermarket
is potentially excessive
and i would suggest that many of the
concerns could be mitigated
through the reduction in capacity of
parking in addition to this continued
booking system which has such a positive
impact
upon these ongoing concerns and as we
come out of the pandemic it could be
that these
um consistent booking systems are going
to become the new normal now i know that
may not be
a planning consideration you would
normally take on board but i would urge
you
to consider that by reducing the number
of parking spaces to reduce the capacity
which is the
the ongoing and consistent complaint and
obviously
the applicants have advised us that the
overspill is to prevent people parking
on the highways i would suggest that's
another conversation with highways to
prevent parking
on that road as it's simply not suitable
for it
so by expanding beyond what was expected
it could be argued it is now expanding
beyond the site
and the surroundings and it could also
be argued that the site can no longer
facilitate
such expansion and the countryside
around it simply cannot tolerate it
so i'd just urge you to think about the
one gift you possibly have as a
committee this evening
is to look at the car parking spaces as
louise actually mentioned in her report
and she advised about regarding thinking
about the balance involved
in whether building up the business and
having the subsequent parking spaces was
necessary
but did raise the point that is quite a
it's quite a lot of parking
for a pub of this size and to get back
to your question sheriff somebody passed
by the pub pre-caffeine in the machine
it never appeared that active lovely
place to visit but it wasn't bustling it
wasn't busy so it's a massive change for
the residents
of this area thank you
thank you donald thank you very much for
that speech
members do you have any questions for
our ward member please indicate in the
chat if you
do i'm seeing a series of shaking heads
at the moment
i'll give you a couple of seconds
looks like there's going to be very
little action counselors on it looks
like you've covered all points that
members needed thank you very much
you're welcome to carry on
uh watching from from where you are okay
um we will now move to points of
clarification
to our officers now we'll remind members
that we do have the benefit of ben ellis
with us today benelux is one of our
licensing
officers um so if we have any questions
that revolve around licensing
which i certainly do uh we'll put them
to him
um i will open up two questions from our
panel first before i go so councillor
dixon first please
thank you chairman could i possibly ask
for the opinion of
the planners then or possibly the
licensing officer if it's an
environmental
aspect regarding obviously the issue is
noise
if we are minded as a committee i
believe we could
require that the landscaping scheme
should incorporate
sound reducing features by way of a
fence on that bund
is that a practical possibility is my
question to the planet
uh should i answer that one mr chair if
you're able to bend that would be great
thank you yeah yeah okay
first of all i'm uh environmental
protection officer i'm not a licensing
officer i should have
apologized um the um the first thing to
say we
read the um rita buns um
absolutely i um uh uh
sympathize with mrs russell and uh the
residents there
and and the change of use that's
happened on on the car park there
and i have given this very careful
consideration
um vegetation in itself although it
provides
uh screening um so it's out of sight out
of mind
acoustically it doesn't actually provide
any mitigation as such the best
mitigation
is indeed buns walls
and fences all of which have their own
visual impacts and immunity impacts
having a large barrier
next to your property uh can sometimes
be
even worse than the exposure from from
the noise
from a noise point of view um it
i i wouldn't be able to to
recommend that that that course of
action um i don't think it would provide
a significant uh reduction
um given the the context of the area
uh and the amount of time that the car
park would be in use that it would
provide benefit
okay lovely thank you while we've got
you ben if i may i've got a couple of
questions about noise and the booking
system as well and festivals
uh which was raised by our war member my
understanding and please do correct me
if i'm wrong is um
the majority of noise levels and in
particular festivals
are governed by the licensing um act
rather than by planning law um and
similarly
a booking system if we were to attempt
to introduce that now that should
really be covered by the license to
operate on the
site rather than be done through
planning am i right in that
assessment or is there some other way to
look at it
uh yes it can all be covered by the
license particularly the um
it's the concern about it becoming a
festival site that's something that's
um often been mentioned to me and
was of course uh the subject of the
2019 license application
whereby originally the area was
for surrounded the premises license was
was to seek for
regulated entertainment uh but that was
uh
withdrawn so that element was withdrawn
so they could now only have
small crowds uh for for music in the
ground so
um i don't believe there's an intention
to
to have that that sort of um uh
uh activity on on the site
um and uh secondly the the booking
system um seems to be
working well again that is something
that can be incorporated into the
premises license
uh if that needs to be regularized
um but uh that they are
very uh amenable to incorporating these
management
techniques ordinarily through
cooperation anyway
oh i think you're on mute counselor
richards sorry i do apologize
and it was whilst one might have no
intention at this point to
host a festival it that might change in
the future i think from a
um for the benefit of
the public for members um and in
watching and interested in this site
am i right in thinking that no festival
could happen outside of the current
licensing
um uh permission unless an application
is put
to allow it they to have
uh regulated entertainment to crowds of
more than 500
people um they would need to amend their
premises license that's correct
that answers that question um and with
the booking system i think that's a
great idea but obviously that's part of
the licensing
system how often does the license get
reviewed is it on an annual basis or is
it as and when
a series of complaints or other
interested comments have been made
that's that's a very good question the
the premises license doesn't
automatically get reviewed the
review is processes triggered by
either responsible authorities that are
licensing authority or
environmental health could trigger a
review or indeed local residents
um could trigger a review so if they
felt that the noise impacts
um were um severe or that
um the prop the premises wasn't
upholding the um
prevention of public nuisance objective
then they could call for the premises
licensing for review
and additional conditions could be
applied if it was deemed to be necessary
by the licensing committee
okay lovely that answers all my
questions thank you very much indeed
and councilman mills has a question for
you as well please actually it's for
louise
okay yeah please go ahead hi louise um
louise um the the new entrance uh
to uh caffeine machine to the car park
how far is that from
from the uh house hill cottage it's
approximately 50 meters
it is 50 meters is it yes okay that's
that's all i want to know at the moment
thank you thank you very much cancer
mills louise while we've got you
as well i have i did have a question and
now i've just lost it oh yes
um with the uh i can't
quickly find which number condition uh
refers to
the landscaping plan so i can't see
whether it refers to there being mature
trees
uh being planted would you have an
objection with that being included
within that condition or is it better
served going in as a note if if members
are minded
it can it can be added as a note because
um the the wording of the condition
gives us
a scope to ensure
that if mature trees are planted
we will have to be careful and mindful
of the fact if the neighbor has got
subsidence we certainly don't want to be
planting
types of tree species within quite
invasive root systems
but i'm sure some sort of compromise and
advice from our agricultural officers
uh would be able to get a satisfactory
um and purposeful um
type species type but i would advise it
as a note
okay um it says so it would be to
a note to condition 11. okay
so perhaps that note could uh could be
expanded to say
um maturities in planting um
uh to include agreement with the
neighboring property
something to that extent or including
the discussion
i wouldn't i would leave it really to
our our
uh agricultural officers a landscaping
team
to advise because we're not aware of the
specialism of the neighbor um i would
leave it more to
to us to ensure that we are um
planting something of a type that
can't be uh implemented
but with subsidence clearly in the
forefront of our minds
yeah i think i think the important thing
i'm trying to get to is that mature
trees so it doesn't take 15 years for
them to grow out and actually have an
impact
but also mindful of the fact that the
neighbor does have
uh ground issues um and we need to
obviously resolve that so however you
want to word that note that's mostly how
i would want to put it in
um okay sorry to interrupt can you
clarify what you mean by mature trees
can we deal with that in a second it
hasn't been put in yet we're not in the
debate so
i'll deal with that in a second uh if i
may members do you have any more
questions
for our officers at this point
i am going to assume that's a no in
which case can we open up
to debate who would like to start us off
first
councilor jennings
thanks chairman um very interesting i
mean
the ward members recommendation about
reducing car parking
i can't agree with that at all i mean
you're basically trying to restrict a
business viability
and putting a limit on its success
i think in in the current environment
the hospitality sector needs as much
help and support as it can get
um i agree that we need to put in some
sort of condition on
and if you could put in mature trees i
think that would be great
um but i've got no hesitation at all
in recommending that we go ahead with
the officer's recommendation and grant
this application so i'd like to formally
put that forward
okay thank you is that a formal proposal
to include the note about mature trees
it is indeed
okay in that case at this point we do
need to go back to the point that uh mr
barker made about what we mean by mature
trees
in my mind it's basically it's not
saplings um
things of a relative mature state
i'm not a tree expert i don't know what
a relative mature state
is in years uh perhaps our officers
could guide us with that
yeah mr barker if you want to come back
can i suggest a figure of three metres
chair hi
i'm more than happy with that counselor
jennings are you happy with that more
than happy with that as well
that would normally be a like a heavy
standard um
type of um um in terms of a definition
it'd be heavy standard yeah i'm i'm fine
with that thank you well
so if we include that as the note as
part of councillor jennings uh proposal
um just one one other point
can we just clarify that it's the heavy
standards
within the landscaping a belt near
hounds hill cottage or is it how
heavy standards throughout the entirety
of the development
i'm proposing in the boundary the entire
boundary are
you wanting to jennings the boundary not
not the rest of it
just about basically specifically
specifically abutting the uh the
neighboring property so it's that side
please louise that we're specifically
looking at
i'm in agreement with that i've got no
issue with um uh
heavy standard trees elsewhere but it
does obviously need to have an
appropriate
mix particularly what i'm trying to
achieve is some protection
to uh the neighboring property yes
okay we did have a second uh from
councillor kendall
um but before i asked councillor kendall
to do that formally councillor mills has
uh expressed a desire to speak so
councilman mills would you like to come
in now
yes thanks mr chairman yes um caffeine
the machine um it is
a tremendous success i mean i i i know
it well
i've been there myself um and also know
the old hounds hill so there's a a
massive difference between the two
um i i do however have concerns about
um i know we can't control the traffic
and we we're
but we i think we've got to think about
well i'll be a bit to be honest if it
was hell's hill college i'll be
horrified i really would
um it does get extremely busy and if you
go along there on a
um on a normal pre-covered
uh it's it's a bit like a race track um
i know we can't that's not what's in
front of us but i still
think we've got to think about what's
happening in the surrounding areas
um i'm trying to
find a good planning reason why i should
say no
we mustn't have this but i can't at home
but i think we
really must think about um the
neighbours
um in this one
i believe me uh on a good day for uh
the caffeine machine who are you know
fantastic success
it is a bit of a nightmare around there
mr chairman thank you
thank you very much cancer mills
councillor kendall would you like to
come in and second formally second your
or the proposal
yes i do i formally second that um i
think the
i think what council mills is saying it
comes back to a lot of the training we
have
when we become uh district councillors
and we
go on to planning committees if we can't
find a good planning
reason to go against something then we
have to go with it
um and i i think i don't want to delay
the point too much
and delay things council jennings said
everything that i
was thinking really i can't find a good
reason i do have sympathy for the
neighbors i really do
but if you can't find a good planning
reason then
we go i go with the uh officer's
recommendation in this case
well i'll leave it at that i agree
councillor kendall thank you very much
councillor dixon next please
thank you chairman yes i'm going to say
i agree that uh where we've
got the planning reasons etc we should
go along with the uh with the
recommendations etc
uh but that doesn't prevent us from
trying to uh make improvements
now obviously a suggestion there has
been made for mature trees but we heard
from the officer that vegetation has
very little impact
upon noise reduction whereas
a sound barrier a fixed fence sound
barrier would have some reduction in the
noise
we obviously have in the report a
comment
that the uh the music noise and the
noise from the vehicles of the site
will not have an unacceptably
significant
impact therefore there will be an impact
it's acknowledged by the officers
there'll be an
impact on noise i think we have a duty
to reduce that
and vegetation will not do it we've
heard that this evening
so i am proposing that not only do we
have a landscaping
police provision but that provision
includes
a fixed sound reduction barrier by way
of a fence
ideally on that bond not necessarily on
the boundary of the property but on the
bond which is
inside the the property as such and a
little bit further away
so that my proposal i don't if anybody
will second that
suggestion and whether or not would that
have would have to be voted on as a
part of that condition thank you
chairman uh thank you very much we'll
come to that in a second um i will ask
councillor curtis to speak
first he has indicated his desire to so
counselor curses
thank you chair um i fully understand
counselor kendall's point about
objections
can only be made on planning grounds
but i'm i am also struggling to
understand
how granting this
which will encourage a considerable
increase
in very high performance vehicles
creating
additional air and noise pollution
sits with the council's climate
emergency
i really struggle i know that's not
necessarily relevant
but perhaps it should be as we move
forward
thank you chair thank you curtis
councillor fleming has indicated his
desire to speak so i think this may be
our last speaker but councillor fleming
yeah um just just sort of uh
picking up on what david says and i
don't i don't want to lock horns with
him but
in reality if this was a vegan
restaurant you'd still have to drive to
it
you know there isn't there is no way of
getting to this without going in a car
so from that perspective part of this
argument about
all its cars coming here kind of falls
down
and so from that perspective i think
we're focusing probably too much on the
fact that it's motor cars
because if it was i don't know something
some other sort of situation
vehicles would still have to drive to it
either on
cars motorbikes or whatever so i think
focusing purely on the extra pollution
if it was busy for whatever purpose you
would still have the same problem
that's all i want to say thank you thank
you very much cancer flowing i would
just add to that as well that um as we
all know tesla and exclusively electric
car
do have a performance car other
performance at fully electric
performance cars are available of course
but bear that in mind that we we is
likely to see
a shift towards performance cars that
are fully electric so
it's not just petrol there will be but
they could also be
the electric side um okay there's a lot
to absorb there uh councillor dixon has
suggested uh
that he wants to make a change to one of
the conditions we have had a proposal
from councillor jennings so i'm going to
seek councillor jennings
view on whether he would wish to include
that within his proposal
council jennings are you happy to
include uh fencing
kind of but uh
i don't know what other what other
members views on it are
i have a view it's quite strong but i
shall ask councillor kendall as your
second first if he has a view
well um i i would ask what
dale barker would recommend in this case
it's not a part of
the the application and i'm not sure if
it's a reasonable thing to add
they're not cheap things and my gut
feeling is
probably not an acceptable thing to add
to an application at this point
so i'd want a bit more feedback really i
think i'm inclined to agree with you on
that and
not only that but they're also unsightly
um from the ones i've seen
uh mr barker perhaps you could uh let us
know what your view is
if we were to include that as a
condition yes
thank you chair um yeah councillor
kendall's uh experience
is showing through here uh yes
in my view an acoustic fence on top of
that bond
is so much of a change that i would be
recommending to members that they defer
the application
so that we can discuss it with the
applicant and get a firm proposal in
front of you
which has been subject to consultation
it's been to the parish council it's
been to the local residents
um before you make a decision on it it
is such a large change
i'll also remind you that if i
understood ben correctly
he said he thought in that location it
would have very little effect
i guess because sound is a slippery
article it's it slips around the sides
of fences
um and it may not have the effect that
you're hoping for
but um sorry i you'd have to ask then
that
so my advice would be if you want to go
down that line please
defer it and either ask for us to bring
it back to you or
defer it in order that we achieve that
and then approve it under delegated
powers
following consultation mr barker thank
you very much
completely understood your recollection
just a second councillor jennings
uh your recollection mr barker uh
confirms with mine as well
um uh so uh i i don't think we need to
call ben back in at this point
councillor jennings you've obviously
wanted something to say so go ahead yeah
in light of the light of those comments
um i'd like to stick with my original
proposal
good man thank you very much councilman
mills has indicated i wish to speak
cancer yeah thanks jim i think i think
anything that can
be put there to limit the noise that the
uh neighbors might uh suffer in the
future uh
we we've got we've got to think about it
and i i will oppose well i would support
uh any noise uh
prevention barrier whatever mr chairman
thank you
okay you've got to think you've we've
got to think about the neighbors
thank you i understood thank you i i
look i
i don't think it's lost on us that we do
need to think about the neighbours and
and the discussion clearly has uh has
shown that we are thinking about those
neighbors
what i would say as well to just to add
uh before we move into debate
sorry into uh the proposal and voting
this is a
site where there's been a pub for a
number of years the fact that the pub
prior to caffeine machine wasn't as
active is no reason to
refuse permission to caffeine machine in
fact caffeine and machine have
managed to create a very viable and very
good quality business a very successful
quality business
they should be rewarded for that not
penalized but
we must also be mindful of the planning
law and the impact that has
elsewhere i believe that this moves a
long way towards that in fact if
anything
a lot of the changes are in an effort to
bring traffic away from the highway
to make the flow of visitors a lot
easier a lot more controllable
and therefore will have a benefit to the
direct location
notwithstanding there are still some
sound issues to be resolved for the
direct neighbor
that needs to be dealt with under the
licensing act not through planning
is not a planning issue for us to worry
about right now
um i've said my pen is worth
i would add also cs22 of our core
strategy supports
the uh businesses in rural areas and
particularly the expansion of those
um so once again we have more policy
that does support this
council addiction you've indicated you
wish to speak again you have spoken
three times on this this is
going to be your last bite the cherry
before we move to a vote no problem
chairman uh very briefly uh mr barker
suggested that if we were minded for the
barrier
we should uh adjourn for uh not adjourn
we should postpone it for a future
uh assessment etc by the planners that's
my proposal that we
defer this application for the planners
to consider
such mitigation measures is my proposal
seconded that we defer this decision
thank you very much councillor dixon um
we have a proposal that has been
seconded on the table already i'm gonna
go to that first
before i seek a seconder for yours so on
the table we have a proposal to grant
proposed by council jennings seconded by
councillor kendall to include
a note about mature trees um uh
that the heavyset or medium-heavy set i
think um uh ms coleman had
indicated to us i'm going to go first on
the vote
uh councillor richards four
thank you councillor flemming
council fleming four
thank you councillor kendall councillor
kendall four
thank you councillor crumb that's the
crop for
cue councillor curtis councillor curtis
four
thank you councillor dixon councillor
dixon abstain
can you counsel henshaws sarah thanks
thanks for serving for
thank you councillor jennings counselor
jennings for
mills ah
against
one two three four five six seven four
one against with one abstention chairman
marbles and thank you very much for that
committee therefore resolves to grant
application 20 0 1 335
ful caffeine machine on the bambi road
in ettington
marvelous we have two more uh items to
here tonight gentlemen and ladies so our
next application
is reference twenty zero two nine six
five f u
l that is six mayfield avenue in
stratfor upon aven and our presenting
officer is charlotte dix charlotte
whenever you're ready please do feel
free to start
thank you chairman let me just share my
screen with you
if you can see lovely thank you very
much for confirming
so the site is indicated on the map by
the black circle
the application site is located within
the built-up area boundary and
conservation area of stratford-upon-avon
this slide shows the application site
edged in red
the property is a semi-detached dwelling
located just inside the conservation
area which is indicated by the pink line
this is an application for full planning
permission for a single story rear
extension
to create a study wc and to extend the
kitchen and living area
the proposed ground floor plan on the
screen shows that the extension would
part infill between the existing l shape
of the property
it would project out from the rear
elevation five meters
and the width would be 5.4 meters
this slide shows the proposed rear
elevation
the extension features a flat reef which
would measure 3.15 meters in height
with two roof lanterns bringing the
total height to 3.5 meters
this slide shows the proposed side
elevation as viewed from
number 7 mayfield avenue to the west
this photo shows the existing rear
elevation of the property
the house is already l-shaped with their
two and single-story projection along
the eastern boundary
the proposed extension would infill part
of the space
in this location
this photo is taken panning around
slightly to show the rear elevation of
the application
site on the right hand side with number
seven mayfield avenue on the left hand
side
this photo is taken from the proposed
location of the extension
facing west again towards number seven
mayfield avenue
the existing brick wall between the
properties is visible
and the extension would line through
with the existing side elevation of the
application site
just to clarify there are no updates to
the application
and officer recommendation is to approve
the application
subject to the conditions and notes
which can be found on page 48 of the
agenda
thank you chairman sean thank you very
much for that
members and this has been brought to uh
committee because the applicant is a
council employee
we have no uh registered speakers so we
will go straight to points of
clarification does anyone have a point
of clarification for our officer
i'm seeing nothing in the chat and i'm
seeing lots of shaken heads
so we will move straight into debate um
i would like to start i propose that we
grant in line with the officer's
recommendation
counselor kendall has indicated his
desire to speak counselor kendall and
councillor kendall would like to second
that uh there's no objections from any
anybody at all um
i think we should uh grab this one
marvelous uh thank you very much uh does
anyone else want to say anything during
the debate
seeing some shaking heads again nothing
in the chat no okay we will move
straight to a vote in that case
council richards four thank you
councillor
fleming casa fleming4 thank you
councillor
answer kendall thank you councillor
trump
mr crumpfort thank you councillor curtis
councillor curtis four thank you
councillor dixon
councillor dixon four thank you
council hench the surfer pennsylvania
seraphin four
councillor jennings chelsea jennings for
cube councillor mills council mills for
you know mr chairman and thank you very
much it sounds like you're struggling
with your throat so we'll try and go
easy on you for the rest of the meeting
um committee therefore resolves to grant
application 202
965 ful at six mayfield avenue in
stratford upon haven
okay let's move to our final item for
the evening which is application twenty
zero
three five three three ful one five
seven eastern road in stratford-born
even our presenting officer is joe brook
joe welcome thank you for your patience
whenever you're ready
please do feel free to start right let
me just share the screen
yep can you see that oh it's just gone
to your desktop yeah
that's right let me just play them
lovely brilliant thanks
the aftercase site is located in the
physical confines at least some road
of stratfor upon avon as indicated by
the black dot as indicated by the plan
before you
this application seeks planning
permission for a single story side
extension
two story rear extension and a new porch
entrance and a garage at the front of
the dwelling
that said this application is being
reported to committee because it was
submitted by a family member of a member
of staff
the application is amendment to an
earlier permission
and the relationship with the impact and
the immediate of the neighbors
at 158 and 156 is unchanged
from that early approval which is still
extend
i'll go into some more detail in two
seconds
these are the existing elevations so
as you can see this is basically what is
there right as it currently stands
without the extent permissions
this is the recently approved
application
under 20 reference zero zero 597 full
so i would like you just to take quick
note of the side
elevations so i can show the differences
so these are the fundamental differences
being proposed for this application as
you can see the dormant window
here will be changed to accommodate uh
more
within the first floor and the main
difference is they are proposing a
so that extension there to a rear
elevation
to also accommodate more living space
above the kitchen
uh within the dwelling
these are the previously blues plans in
comparison to the proposed floor plans
so best ways to do it is this is going
to be
the first floor extension so you can see
we'll be on that area and that's the
slight amendment to the door in the
window area there
which would be over sorry just over
there
sees the photographs this is a dwelling
subject to the application
this is the neighboring property so
obviously extension will come down here
and that's one five eight
this is to rear once again that's one
five eight so that's the rear half of
the
dwelling in question this is one
five six so obviously that's where the
um
ground floor extension will come and
then the box extension
first floor and that's the end of
presentation
uh overall the pros development yeah
would respect the
existing financial australian built form
in terms of
mass will ensure an adequate living
amenities for future residents while
respecting the neighboring amenities
i sat out in the office report the
application is considered comply with
all parties requirements
especially considering the recent
approved extent permission
on the site therefore officer
recommendation
is for approval subject to the
conditions and notes set out in the
report
thank you joe thank you very much uh for
that full and comprehensive uh
presentation we will go straight to our
speakers we only have one
uh registered here and that is counselor
curtis councillor curtis you know the
drill
five minutes use as much or as little as
you wish i will give you a 30 second
warning if you go too long
and whenever you're ready feel free
thank you very much chair
can we see i will be as brief as
possible um joe
could you bring up yeah that's it thank
you very much
this application has raised several
concerns with the immediate neighbors mr
mrs drajewski at number one
five eight evention road the most
pressing
issue is the impact the proposed
extension will have on light
entering their side sitting room
this room directly faces the proposed
side extension
to number 157 and it does appear
inadvertently that this may not have
been taken
into account in the previous reports
presented to this committee
either in october or this evening
in these reports the section on
residential amenity
on page 54 paragraph 5
states the proposed rear extension
would not breach the 45 stroke 25 degree
rule
from any ground or first floor
rear window at number 158
this may be correct but unfortunately
the report omits any mention of the side
window
at number 158 if the committee views
this slide
you can see i believe i hope a dotted
line
showing the angle from the midpoint of
the side window
which is 58 degrees to the
to the end of the proposed extension
which significantly breaches the
45 degree rule in fact
a substantial increase of nearly 30
percent
i'd invite the committee to consider
whether this difference of nearly 30
percent
58 degrees rather than 45 degrees
goes beyond what the committee may
reasonably considered to be marginal
mr and mrs jodruska certainly feel this
will result in considerable loss of
light to their sitting room
and having visited the property recently
i do find myself in agreement with them
given this i would ask members of the
committee to carefully consider
whether you are able to agree with the
conclusions on page 67
paragraph 2. quote
the proposed development would not
result in
any material harm being caused to the
immunity of neighboring residents
by way of a loss of light
the relevant side of the property is
easily accessible through a large side
gate
and i'm sure a site visit by a member of
the planning team
would quickly provide the committee with
the relevant information
on which a fully informed decision could
be taken
mr chairman i therefore ask that this
application is refused as it currently
stands
or at the very least any decision can be
deferred
until such time as the committee is able
to have this additional
and pertinent information that wasn't
previously presented
thank you very much for your time
cheering committee casa curtis thanks
very much we have got a question for you
councillor dixon
would like to ask one councillor dixon
councillor curtis
uh is the window that uh is the
neighbor's concern a principal window of
that room
obviously you mentioned it's a sitting
room that it serves but is it as
the principal or a secondary window
there
thank you council dixon there are two
windows in the room
both of equal size i would say
so um it's it's
yes there are two windows of equal size
is the other window
um not on the side of the building but
on the front or rear
no they're both windows on the side the
room in question
the sitting room in question only has
side two side facing windows
thank you and so can i just clarify
counselor
um the report
mentions that there is no impact on
uh on light to the on windows to the
rear of the property
but unfortunately it seems
to have omitted the impact on side
windows to the adjacent property
that's very much understood and you you
articulated that
perfectly well in your your speech so
thank you we will ask that i will ask
that to the officers
um we don't have any further questions
for you at this point cancer curtis but
thank you very much for
your contribution we will move to points
of clarification to our officers
joe guess what question i'm going to ask
right um so i take it the breach the 45
degree on the side windows
yes please let me there's a few points i
need to raise here let me just
share my presentation again
can i really see that yes good um
so fundamentally i'm gonna go to this
slide here just because obviously
they're not scale drawings but it gives
you a good indication what's proposed in
full
is that i have to highlight regardless
of the 45 degree breach
the permission for these like dimensions
have already been permitted
whether this is refused here today or
not
the applicant has every right within the
next three years at
october 23 to implement
these um commissions so you can quite
clearly see
the side elevations have already been
approved
so also set on report
it does say that there is some reach to
the 25 degree line
on the side two facing windows but it
was negligible because of the one point
because they could have a two meter side
property boundary fence so it was deemed
at that time to be appropriate
and then therefore that's why it's a bit
got approved brief
previously and now
the fundamental differences are just
this normal window and this aspect here
which
i would have to ask committee to
consider most relevant
the other bit that i would just quickly
highlight is that
this is a floor plan of 158 each
road the two side wind facing windows
are these two here
which is a secondary living room the
main sitting room is here so when the
officer did
her conclusion she did take into account
there's actually a secondary living room
and the spd does state that let me just
quickly make sure
that side facing windows won't be given
the same level protection
as front facing and rear-facing windows
so in all on planning balance it was
determined that
it was sufficient in respect to this
application
i hope that makes sense it makes perfect
sense to me
so before you go on if i can add to that
um if you turn to page 54 of your agenda
and look at the third paragraph down
it clearly shows that this issue was
addressed both with the previous
application
and with this application
and i'm i'm strongly advising you that
whatever
interpretation is put on the 45-25 rule
and
my personal view is it's not conflicted
by this but putting that to one's side
the fallback position is is king here
the applicant
can build this extension and the only
change
is the flat roof extension on the other
side of the house which is having no
impact on
uh 158 eastern road thank you chair
understood thank you um i i thought joe
brought that out perfectly well
what i would ask you uh mr spark if you
don't uh if you don't mind
we all have to use the chat in order to
speak it helps with the flow of the
meeting i'd be grateful if you could do
the same
rather than interrupting i know you've
got things to say but um
if you could please use the chat i'd be
grateful apologies okay
um councillor mills has a question
please councilman yeah
thanks jim uh hi joe uh joe could you
um put up on the screen uh
the before and after the original
application and this application
and
so it that's what he's
sorry that's approved and that's what's
proposed as part of this application and
uh sorry i i couldn't quite say
would it when it take up more area than
the old one
the best way to show that character is
to show the floor plans
so you can see on the floor plans ground
floor
growing floor same dimensions first
floor
first floor dimensions so same
dimensions
that's all i need to know thank you
joseph
marvelous there being no more questions
for our officers we will move
into debate who would like to kick us
off
shall i do that oh councillor jennings
is here council james
um obviously the fallback position here
is that is extremely important
um there's i see no material planning
reasons to go against the officer's uh
decision here um i'd like to formally
propose that
we go ahead and grant this application i
appreciate that the
the the win the side window
issue but that has been addressed so uh
let's go ahead and propose thank you
councillor jennings we have had two
members wish to second i will go with
our first one uh which is councillor
kendall would you like to formally
uh second please i would like to
formally second for all the reasons
uh council jennings just stated
marvelous thank you very much we will
move to a vote then i would just say
that um
whilst the point that was raised by our
ward member was a valid one
it has been covered off to my mind more
than ably by
by both joe and uh and dale as well um
so with that uh council richards four
thank you councillor fleming catcher
flaring for
thank you councillor kendall councillor
kendall four
thank you councillor comp cancer
thank you cancer dickson councillor
dixon
iv you can say seraphin
council entrance seraphim four
councillor jennings councillor jennings
for
councillor mills country mills for
unanimous chairman thank you very much
chad so committee therefore resolves to
grant applications twenty zero
three five three three ful one five
seven eastern road instructor upon haven
there being no urgent business it leaves
me to thank
uh all of our officers um for their
support and help today all of you as
members for your contributions today and
in particular
to all of those people that have uh
spoken uh and taken part in two nights
me
in tonight's meeting thank you again
everyone and we will see you in a couple
of weeks time
good job